a un año de la masacre de melilla No hay
ninguna investigación judicial abierta
ni en España ni en Marruecos para
señalar a los responsables de la que fue
la mayor tragedia jamás vivida en la
frontera de este enclave español el 24
de junio de 2022 en dicha frontera
murieron al menos 23 personas según las
autoridades 40 personas según los
colectivos de defensa de Derechos
Humanos eso cuando la policía quiso
abortar con violencia un intento de
salto de las vallas que separan
Marruecos de España ese día 470 personas
lograron acceder a territorio español y
fueron expulsadas de forma inmediata y
sin ningún tipo de garantías a Marruecos
también hay cerca de 80 personas
desaparecidas desde la fecha gran parte
de los supervivientes acabaron siendo
encarcelados en el país
les condenaron por los delitos de
favorecer la inmigración clandestina de
ultraje a las autoridades entre otros
cargos y también muchas personas
siendo trasladadas de forma forzada a
lugares remotos de Marruecos donde
siguen bloqueadas como consecuencia de
la externalización de fronteras de la
Unión Europea la mayoría de víctimas de
la masacre de melilla son demandantes de
asilo que huyen de la guerra
concretamente de la guerra de Sudán un
año después solamente una de las
personas que murieron ha podido seguir
identificada y enterrada en Marruecos y
mientras ven como la guerra se recrudece
en su país los supervivientes y sus
familiares siguen exigiendo justicia
verdad y reparación